in a still photograph North Korea's
dictator Kim Jong-un is sitting in front
of what the official news service says
was a new underwater drone other photos
purport to show it at Sea where North
Korea claimed it had cruised for 59
hours before detonating armed with a
nuclear warhead North Korea said it
could cause a radioactive tsunami
that could be used to attack enemy Naval
units or ports
Kim Jong-un also apparently watched
Conventional Weapons test too cruise
missiles being moved on mobile launchers
and then being fired into the ocean
North Korea claims these can carry
nuclear warheads too though military
analysts are skeptical it has the
technology at least yet
this most recent flaunting of Weaponry
which last week included a
submarine-launched missile is a response
to U.S South Korean military exercises